what do you think about the bitcoin etf
is it likely to get approved not get
approved uh do you think it matters
well uh the etf that gensler has
signaled he wants would be the futures
based etf um which would be an inferior
product in my mind uh you know might
have an additional 10 drag in there
because the cost of rolling futures
um spot etfs work fine we've seen them
work in canada we see them work in
europe there's nothing unexpected or
complicated about them you're just
literally holding bitcoin then you have
daily liquidity and it equilibrates so
it tracks the price really closely a
futures base etf is an inferior product
uh it's just less efficient right
but that looks like what we're gonna get
i wouldn't be surprised i think the
first deadline is the 18th
of this month
and there's a whole bunch of pending
applications i think we probably will
get
a futures-based etf and i think we're
going to continue to be stonewalled on
the spot etf side which is what we all
really want
and that would be the blockbuster
product that would see hundreds of
billions in inflows that would have more
inflows than gld did within its first
week uh which i think was the hottest
edf launch ever so
so we're on the 14th now so monday
basically is when the they have to give
an answer on the futures can they kick
the can down the road or do they have to
make a decision um that's a great
question i think that might have to be a
like a resubmit your application type
thing yeah if they if they it's a reject
or accept it's not uh hey we postpone
our decision yeah i mean they've had uh
like six months already to kind of say
something about it so okay uh so if you
had to guess now you think it gets
approved was the futures yeah and it's
just you know ultimately not a very
compelling product you might see a
couple billion in inflows but uh that's
just not what investors deserve i mean
and the weird thing is you're allowed to
have like a 4x inverse
levered
uh you know natural gas tracking etf
that like mathematically will decline by
95 percent a year
um and that's permissible
and a spot etf tracking one of the
largest commodity markets in the world
traded in hundreds of jurisdictions very
sophisticated market infrastructure is
not allowed why do you think that is
politically i'm certain at this point
yeah i mean
like most most of you like etf analysts
at bloomberg will say the same thing
that there's a political gating factor
for the etf
uh which is simply that uh you know they
they don't want bitcoin to gain uh the
sort of authority and the blessing of
the sec
because like all of the challenges the
sec has made to
the sponsors of those etfs have been met
there's no question about that
and if you look at
the standards being applied to other
commodity markets where price
manipulation does happen i mean hell
the biggest market in the world uh libor
was manipulated right but that doesn't
mean you can't have financial products
tracking interest rates right uh silver
had an infamous episode of price fix and
that doesn't mean there isn't a silver
etf right so
writing off bitcoin by saying oh we
don't like the market structure you know
there's episodes of manipulation that
doesn't make sense it's not the standard
uh so they're applying some sort of
uneven standard bitcoin versus all other
commodities